let's start of the auto market now in a
potential problem for one of four words
best-selling trucks the f-150 for it's
been at least 1 billion dollars
overhauling the vehicle to meet stricter
regulatory requirements the problem some
versions still falls short according to
a Washington research company forty
percent of the new aluminum body models
don't meet 2016 mandates one variation
comes up short on both emission and fuel
economy mandates let's begin David Wells
who covers deals for Bloomberg News he
joins us from our Detroit newsroom David
how big of a deal and how fast could
forward get this fixed well right now
it's it's not a problem for forward this
year in other words the fact that forty
percent of the trucks they sell don't
meet the fuel economy standards right
now isn't a big deal only because the
total fleet average meets the overall
fuel economy rules bigger problem comes
down the line this is their best foot
forward in terms of fuel economy because
they put so much aluminum into it and a
lot of other technology advancements so
as the fuel economy rules get tougher
and they will get a lot tougher over the
next ten years there they could have a
real challenge in meeting those rules
and selling these trucks and this is
where they make the most money so
they're going to have to do some more
things to these trucks to get them even
more efficient as all the companies who
sell pickup trucks are going to have to
do over the next decade we've seen all
these companies scrambling to do that
David some with mixed effect here I
think of Volkswagen and others that have
sort of juice the results a little bit
here is there a risk that we're at the
point where you can't make a large
pickup truck more efficient there are
going to be trade-offs unless they can
really get the technology pushed forward
one of the big trade-offs would probably
be cost of the trucks themselves pickup
trucks that have had the the fastest
rise and sticker price of any vehicle on
the market and part of that's because of
things like lightweight aluminum in the
Ford are more advanced engines or you
know hybrid systems that cost a lot of
money so to get something like this that
is really efficient and hep but has a
big job to do it needs a certain amount
of power to haul trailers and tow and
and and you know carry big payloads in
those beds you're going to have to put
some real technology in there you can't
just make the car slower or more
aerodynamic like you would with a
passenger car a family sedan a more
compact what will it do we'll make it
let me give necessary
with fuel-ups the f-150 more regularly
will it be more expensive for the driver
well they're going to probably have to
pass these costs on somehow right if
they had more technology to it yeah that
will get passed on to the consumer in
some ways now it all you could also look
at some point the consumer could kind of
push back and stop buying the trucks and
then 42 left to eat some of that and
profitability does get tougher on car
makers as they have to put more
technology into all kinds of vehicles
those two 2025 hurdles I imagine are
what really motivating these car
companies here but we've seen gas prices
so low I can only imagine that that's
cause these companies may be to put
making cars more efficient on the back
burner that US consumers might not be as
inclined to go out and buy more
fuel-efficient vehicles on their own to
elect to do that it really has because
if you go back not even ten years
everybody was trying to meet tougher
standards but fuel got up to you know
higher than four dollars a gallon
consumers were buying more efficient
stuff they were demanding it so you saw
things like the Toyota Prius really
booming in sales all that stuff is down
now and it really puts the car companies
in a pickle because they have to make
efficient vehicles and add technology
and lightweight materials just to meet
the rules but consumers have gone back
to buying SUVs and luxury cars and
pickup trucks